مشاهدينا الى السودان حيث افاد مراسل
الجزيره بتجدد القصف المدفعي مترافقا مع
تحليق للطيران الحربي في سماء العاصمه
الخرطوم وكانت الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع قد تجددت منذ
امس في مدن العاصمه الثلاث الخرطوم
والخرطوم بحري وام درمان وافاد مراسلنا
بسماع اصوات اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله في
شارع الغابه والمنطقه الصناعيه والحل
الجديده غربيه الخرطوم كما شهدت مناطق
امدرمان اشتباكات وسمع دجارات متتاليه
جنوبيه المدينه وفي منطقه بحري شماليه
الخرطوم
قالت مصادر طبيه في ولايه غرب دارفور اذا
الاحداث الامنيه التي شهدتها الولايه خلفت
اكثر من الفي جريح معظمهم من النساء
والاطفال واعلنت المصادر عن وفاه جميع
مرضى غسيل الكلى في مدينه الجنينه عاصمه
الولايه اشار تقرير طبي الى نفاذ المحاليل
والمضادات الحيويه وعدم امكانيه ايصال
المساعدات للجنينه بسبب انتشار القناصه
معنى لان الخرطوم مراسل للجزيره الطاهر
المرضي اذا الانباء تتحدث عن الشباكات
ايضا دوليا بالعاصمه الخرطوم والاوضاع
تذهب في اتجاه من سيء الى اسوا ان كان في
القطاع الصحي او في قطاعات اخرى في
العاصمه الطاهره التفاصيل لديك
نعم هذا هو الواقع حيث بدات الحرب منذ
ساعات الاولى من الصباح
بالانفجارات والاسلحه الثقيله هنالك في
غرب ام درمان ثم هنا في وسط الخرطوم في
شارع الغابه في هذه المناطق والمناطق
المجاوره لهذه الاحياء جميعها تعرضت ايضا
للقصف والاشتباكات ثم انتقل هذا القصف
المدفعي من جنوب الخرطوم في اتجاه الجنوب
في هذه المناطق ثم في شرق النيل وفي منطقه
بحري يبدو ان هذه المناطق تحديدا تصبح من
المناطق الاستراتيجيه للقتال خاصه وان هذه
الاشتباكات بدات تتجدد فيها كل يوم
وتتراجع فيها حده هذه الاشتباكات ثم
تتصاعد مره اخرى ولكن بصفه عامه هذه هي
اجواء الخرطوم هي اجواء بلا هدنه بلا توقف
بلا اي نوع من المراقبه
السقف هو اول التعامل هو البندقيه
والتعامل بالاسلحه الثقيله وكذلك الطيران
هذا ايضا ينطبق على ولايات في دارفور اذا
كان هنالك ايضا اشتباكات عنيفه في محليه
كتب بولايه شمال
دارفور حيث كان هنالك عدد كبير من الضحايا
في هذه المنطقه وكذلك من الجرحى وتشرد
المئات من هذه المدينه الى جهاد لا توجد
فيها حتى مساعدات انسانيه وايضا في ولايه
غرب دارفور في مدينه الجنينه عدد الجرحى
يتجاوز الالفين توقف الكهرباء المياه
وكذلك الاتصالات وخروج المنظمات الانسانيه
من هذه المدينه كل ما ياتي من اخبار في
هذه المناطق تعتبر اخبار ماساويه لمساعدات
انسانيه ولا حتى انقاذ النوع من
الجرحى وهذه هي الامور بهذا الشكل وحتى
الان ليس هنالك اي تطور سياسي او اي نوع
ما يمكن ان يوصف بانه يشكل يعني بارقه امل
لوقف قريب لاطلاق النار في السودان شكرا
جزيلا لك من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره الطاهر
المرضي